well I'm joined now by the journalists
at Philip pangalos is also in Athens
forest Philip thanks very much for
joining us on Sky News it was a marathon
session in the capital there have been
marathon negotiations in Brussels as
well do you think most Greeks will wake
up feeling relieved or betrayed by this
result bit of both think more relief at
the end of the line as you as you said
earlier the alternative doesn't bear
thinking about falling you know a
disorderly default and falling out of
the eurozone really would be
catastrophic dying Greeks have suffered
enough in the past five years of
austerity and the last five or six
months and obviously in the last two
weeks since capital controls will come
into place and banks of clothes so
people are being very worried I mean
they're not happy i think overall about
the deal they feel they've been
blackmailed into a bad deal which has
more recessionary motors even though
there is scope for debt relief and a
sizable fun 35 billion for growth under
the young current project so there is a
bright side to as well but i think
people overall are relieved and going on
what you were saying earlier on the pole
we had just this week something like
eighty percent of greeks want to stay in
the eurozone and something like seventy
percent wanted their government to vote
for these proposals to 19 and they were
carried right with a large majority i
mean we had 229 yes vote 64 no votes six
of sanctions causing the key question is
that i think alexis tsipras government
has come out to wounded i think after
tonight's vote because he had 39 of his
own a series of MPs who didn't back him
i think there were 32 no votes six
abstentions and one absentee so that's
quite a what a blow for him and that
includes a handful of ministers and
former ministers and as you said that
includes the former finance minister
Yanis varoufakis the parliamentary
speaker zoe goes in the pool and a
couple of other senior ministers oh my
god is like a zionist who's the energy
minister is that leader of the so-called
left factions is a hard left grouping
within his party have been opposed to
more austerity which not forgetting mr.
tsipras was elected on a pledge not to
have more austerity and he's got a lot
more austerity for the next three years
but there'll be a relief they'll be
looking to an ECB meeting later today
which hopefully will
of more emergency liquidity to Greek
banks and help keep them open because
they were on the verge of collapsing and
also looking to be able to get this
seven billion of intermediate funding
that's being talked about which will
help them pay 3.5 billion that's due
next week to the ECB so they need money
quick this is just the beginning hard
times ahead I wouldn't be surprised to
see a cabinet reshuffle as early as
tomorrow because as we said a number of
his own ministers vote against measures
and you can't see how they will be able
to implement the reforms they're going
to be asked to implement so tough times
ahead he's thorough not out of the woods
yet and there's also a risk down the
line if they can't get this together he
might might even have to form a national
unity government he has after all lost
his majority out of 149 since that is
has he has excuse me and another 13 with
his junior coalition partner independent
Greeks they're down to 123 now after
tonight's if you count two night sweats
but they've just escaped the dangerous
121 limit which under the Greek
Constitution means they would have to
have given over to a caretaker
government Philip you've been talking
about what's been going on inside
Parliament but there's also been some
protests many protests outside
parliament as well do you think this is
just the start of much more to come
quite possibly as you said earlier on it
was minority of people there were a few
thousand people out there and it was
only dozens maybe a hundred or so who
spent and causing one and threw petrol
bombs and rocks at riot police who has
always returned fire with tear gas and
stun grenades but you know there are
messy scenes in the centre of Athens
it's not the sort of thing we want to
see several cars were torched windows
lots of shots had their windows smashed
banks were vandalized you know it's not
not exactly pleasant having said that
I've seen a lot worse not for some time
not for a year year and a half or so but
obviously a couple of years ago the peak
of the rights we had we had a lot worse
scenes with a lot more people out there
rioting it's going to be tense times and
difficult times for Greece for Greeks
and especially sofa mr. Alexis tsipras
Pangalos in Athens for us thank you